we are learning more tonight about
wednesday's raid at the manhattan home
of former new york mayor and
presidential attorney rudy giuliani
correspondent david spunt reports
tonight from the justice department
president biden insists he was not
briefed in advance on the fbi's plan
to raid former new york mayor rudy
giuliani's home i give him my word i was
not i made a pledge
i would not interfere in any way order
or try to stop
any investigation the justice department
had underway but attorney general
merrick garland and fbi director
christopher wray
were well aware before agents moved in
taking cell phones computers and
other electronics fox news has learned
neither
ordered the raid but were given a
courtesy heads up before it happened
standard practice a law enforcement
source
says discussions of a giuliani raid
began
months ago during bill barr's tenure as
attorney general
though officials declined to move
forward so help me god
but when joe biden became the 46th
president the investigation picked up
steam
and quickly when you're putting together
an application for a search warrant like
this
that's something that takes an extreme
amount of
focus of evidence you need to persuade a
federal judge
to approve the search warrant multiple
sources tell fox news
the focus of the federal investigation
surrounds giuliani's ties to ukraine
a country where he made several trips in
an attempt
to dig up dirt on hunter biden also
under federal investigation
he corrupted ukraine and he soiled the
reputation of the united states no one
has said he's done anything wrong except
the thug
rudy giuliani now the former new york
mayor and former federal prosecutor
is under investigation by the same
office he once led
this morning former president trump
defended his friend
it's very very unfair rudy is a patriot
who loves this country and i don't know
what they're looking for
on his last day in office then president
trump pardoned or commuted the sentences
of 144 people not on the list rudy
giuliani
john leaving him wide open for what's
happening before us and just late this
afternoon
giuliani made very brief comments on his
radio show taking shots
at those investigating him while
proclaiming his innocence
john i'm sure we'll hear a lot more from
him in the days and weeks ahead david
spun at the justice department david
thank you